- Do you remember when they
first asked you to host?
- Oh, yeah.
- 'Cause it was such
a random thing, right?
- Well, yes.
They asked me to host and
they didn't know what.
Everybody was flying blind the first year,
including me, 'cause I had
never been to a dog show,
I didn't no know anything about 'em.
They brought the Old English Sheepdog
up to the judge.
- Oh, yeah.
- If you don't know what
an Old English Sheepdog is,
it's 80 pounds of hair and
two pounds of actual dog.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(audience laughs)
Which is awesome!
- So, they brought it up
to the judge who was this
elegantly gowned woman.
So she walks around to
the front of the dog
and she starts picking
through all of the hair
on the dog's head, and I said,
"David, what is she doing now?"
He says, "John, she's
trying to find the eyes
(audience laughs)
"to gauge the attentiveness of the dog."
I said, "Really?"
I said, "Well if she picks
through all of that hair
"and she finds only one eye,
"she's got the wrong end of the dog."
(Kelly and audience laughing)
So you see how far my learning curve was?
That was years ago.
- You said it on air, right?
- Oh, yes.
- I love you so much.
- They have the broadcaster's
comments in the sports section
in "USA Today."
- Yeah, that would be one.
- That was it.
"Wrong end of the dog, John O'Hurley."
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- Okay, so you have such a great voice,
so have you ever done, do you wanna...
I think the dog wants to go for a walk.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
(audience clapping)
(audience and John laughing)
Oh, my God, I love you so much.
She said to the dog,
"Turn around, go back."
- Take him back.
- Oh, my God.
- I lost one.
- Out for your morning
constitutional, were you?
- Physical comedy is the best.
Oh my God, I love you so much.
- Now don't you try that.
(audience laughing)
- Be sure to watch the
National Dog Show tomorrow
along with my sister who never misses it,
Thanksgiving Day on NBC.